so the last question comes from zanthius
he says or she says these models of
consciousness seem to focus on
explaining the production of
intelligence or assimilation but it is
it isn't necessarily clear to me why a
simulation should be able to perceive
slash experience itself if we think of
meta consciousness as a combination of
intelligence and consciousness the model
seems to focus mainly on the rise of
intelligence in meta consciousness how
do you explain the ability to perceive
slash experience the simulation
john you start
um
so
it's just a very short easy question
wrap it up for today with this answering
the simple question
uh i mean the the
it's important to ask that question but
it's important to not ask that question
the wrong way
um you could always ask what it is like
and the thing and this is like moore's
thing about the good i can ask that for
any proposal
you can even ask that well you know what
it's like is to have qualia well what's
it like to have qualia do i have qualia
of my quality like you have to you like
there
and this is the difficulty you have to
come to a place where
you're saying that's what it is like to
be what it is like um and we didn't get
into it too much but like i said at the
very beginning
that primary sense of relevance
and i think is a big piece
of what it's likeness it's with why
things stand out and in our salient and
are backgrounded it's why things are
aspectualized for us to use one of soros
notions um
and many people are converging on the
idea that the function
of consciousness is this kind of higher
order relevance realization and that's
why it overlaps with working memory and
attentional machinery
so
what it's like
if that's right if what it's like is
this ability to
do salience landscaping
to have this dynamic texture of how
things are relevant to you
if that's a big part of what it's like
and i think it is by the way because all
of the in the pure consciousness event
all of those other
things that are so beloved all the
adjectival qualias and all the other
things they go away and consciousness
doesn't so those things can't be
necessary conditions for consciousness
if that's par a significant part of what
it's like
then
being intelligent
is also that being intelligent is this
capacity to zero in on relevant
information exclude relevant information
that's why you get
high correlations between measures of
general intelligence and measures of
working memory uh but of course there's
deep inter there's deep
anatomical relations between the
machinery of working memory and
attention and fluid intelligence and
consciousness so
i think the question is now being
to a place where i want to say no no no
and by the way think of notice how you
run on that you genuinely you gen
you generally attribute
consciousness where you where you
attribute high orders of intel of of
intelligence
you track them together uh like uh uh
joshua i i i don't well i go further i
don't even eat mammals uh because of
that conclusion about mammals next place
yeah well there you go um
and so for me
right there there has to be a level at
which you accept an identity statement
because like i said you can always play
the game no matter what i that is what
it if i say x is what it is like you can
then then you can just do ah but what is
it like to write x you have to come to a
place where you accept the uh i i uh an
identity claim
and i'm proposing to you that if you
look into the guts of intelligence at
least general intelligence fluid
intelligence and then you look into the
guts of consciousness and where do we
need consciousness we seem to need
consciousness for situations that are
novel for that are complex that are
ill-defined and situations that don't
have those demands we can we can make
automatic unconscious
uh that's a good point made by bornstein
i don't think the questions about
intelligence and consciousness are
ultimately separable questions
and i think there's good reasons for
that i've just given you some and
therefore
i think at some level
and i i maybe yosho will like this
when a system is sufficiently
intelligent
it's going to be conscious
that's what i would argue
for the reasons i've just given and
asking me but what is it like to be
intelligent or what's it like to be i
notice you don't ask the question about
what is it like to be conscious in the
sense of what's behind it right you have
to come to a level at which you say
no that's what that's this this is what
it is liking is this is the function
it's performing this is the kind of
process it is
if not if you don't put some bound on
where that identity is possible then you
just get an infinite regret aggressive
this question because no matter what i
pause it for you you can step back and
say but what is it like to x
and then i'll say well what's it like to
x is to y and you'll say but what is it
like to why this is like the
uh the four-year-old asks you why all
the time right you have to come to a
place and what i can't give you is i
can't give you a phenomenological
experience of that
because you're trying to ask how
phenomenological experience is itself
possible
what i can give you are these plausible
arguments about overlapping
functionality etc
that's how i would answer that question
okay let me try
so uh there is an issue for instance
with free will free will is uh
an intermediate representation i think
free will is what decision making under
uncertainty looks like from your own
perspective between discovering the
first person perspective and
deconstructing it again
and once you have distracted
deconstructed your first person
perspective you basically realize that
there is a particular procedure that you
are following when you are making your
decisions
and when you observe yourself following
that procedure you will not have an
experience of free will
it's just we rarely get to the point in
our short lives where we fully
deconstruct this
and
i just give this example to argue for
the possibility and i'm not sure there's
no certainty there that consciousness
might be an intermediate representation
it's best the simplification of the
state of affairs and which we are in
before we automate all the necessary
behaviors that an intelligent system
might have want to exhibit in uh when
it's being confronted with the world in
which we are in
the reason why we
experience things is not because
physical systems would be capable of
doing so it's quite the opposite neurons
cannot experience what it would be like
to be a person that is confronted with a
complex world and it changes its
attitudes in response to what's
happening to it in this complex world
but for the organization of the neurons
that is uh controlling the behavior of
the organism
it would be very useful
to have this
knowledge of what it would be like to be
a person that is changing its attitudes
in response to what's happening to it
so what the neurons are doing is they
implement a model of what that would be
like a simulation of what that would be
like in the same way as the neurons
create a simulation of euclidean
universe with objects that bump into
each other and have causal interaction
the neurons create the model of agents
that try a care about future states and
how they play out and make decisions
about this and one of these agents is
going to be a model of the organism
itself and the behavior that motivates
the organism
and the reason why we experience things
is not because we are in the brain it's
because we are in that model we are in
that simulation we are in that dream
that is woven by the brain to explain
its own behavior the experience sings
for the same reason that the character
in a novel experiences things it's
because it's written in the story
and the story that we experience of
course is not a linear narrative made up
of words
it's a more complicated world it's a
causal structure
that contains
the necessary properties to simulate
physics and personality and agency and
so on
and we find ourselves in that dream
so our experience of the world is
virtual
it's a result of the capacity of neurons
to dream and to create dreams